I did write a new joke there it didn't
work and I just tell see what the joke
is sure maybe it's not funny are we
workshopping no I just I thought it
would been funny but maybe it needs more
right so basically is my dad used to
beat me with golf clubs right and I go
and that's why I hate golf today like I
can't watch I [__] hate it right on
TV he used to beat me with tennis
rackets and if I see a tennis racket I
get PTSD trauma so that I'm so glad my
didn't dad didn't beat me with
[__] the structure is good [__] makes
no sense why because I love [__] and I
what if I if you put me with [__] I
would hate it now yeah yeah yeah that
connection it took a while for my brain
to get there yeah yeah yeah it's so
stupid I would do something other than
[__] but I like when you're like two
things I hate glad I try to do a formula
thing right yeah what a pizza then I'm
so glad my dad didn't beat me with pizza
uh still I can't connect it in my yeah
how why can't you connect it I I
connected I know you connected it um